hello my name is Alison Butler and I am
a Canadian actress from Guelph Canada
I'm here today to talk to you guys about
moving from my home country to Los
Angeles and everything that I've kind of
gone through and hopefully by the end
you guys can relate if you're
considering moving from a foreign
country so I'm very fortunate to have
moved here and I feel very grateful for
this experience
of course it's been filled with some
challenges but also some fantastic
moments so I think the biggest challenge
overall that everyone can probably
relate to once you guys decide to move
here is this concept of starting fresh
for instance the logistics of living
here you have to figure out which
neighborhoods to move to and I had no
knowledge of this what rent I should be
paying because it is quite expensive so
that's something to consider driving you
probably need a car and that can be also
expensive but very worth it getting your
driver's license they're going out the
tax system all of these kind of details
that you take for granted in your home
country and when you come here you're
completely starting over and trying to
build up that understanding the second
idea of this whole starting fresh thing
would be starting over and not knowing
anyone when you move here it can be a
little bit overwhelming but it's
actually quite a wonderful eye opening
experience because you just realize how
wonderful people are wherever you go
of course you're leaving your support
system of your family and friends back
home but you soon learn to build your
own support system here in LA and I
think as an actor that is so important
to have because this industry can be
filled with so much rejection and fear
and this whole daunting word of know so
I think having that support system is so
crucial that's also something to think
about it you're starting fresh with the
people that you're meeting another idea
of this starting over concept is
breaking into the American film industry
so perhaps you have knowledge of
wherever you're from that film industry
and how that operates for me I had
knowledge of the Canadian industry but
then when you come here it's about
building your toolbox as an actor and
understanding the map of LA where the
big cast new studios are
who the agents are where to submit
yourself if you're doing self
submissions and how it just generally
operates in Los Angeles something that
you'll quickly notice if you are moving
here is that there is a great sense of
community with foreigners everyone can
relate to each other we've all had to
sacrifice things back home maybe
financially physically mentally it's
been a daunting experience but you'll
soon see that so many people enjoy this
and it's a great community I've met so
many wonderful producers from South
Africa Brazil actors from Australia
Mexico everyone comes together and
supports each other so knowing that
there is that sense of community is so
helpful when making the decision to move
here because it is quite a welcoming
community and I'm so grateful for that
one final thing I wanted to leave you
guys with is pursuing this industry can
be overwhelming for so many different
reasons and it can be very discouraging
but if you are a foreign actor producer
director making the move to LA that
takes so much courage and perseverance
when you consider how much it took for
you to just make the move that should
give you confidence in pursuing the
industry because if you can do that you
can do a lot of things so I hope this
was helpful I just wanted to share with
you some experiences that I've had and
I'm sure a lot of you can relate and
thank you so much for watching